so welcome back the first speaker of
this afternoon's session is on John
Tom's team so he is working acting I
started working at the University of
Notre Dame he's gonna talk talk about
solving polynomials so this is the first
direction up to so thank you Hiro and I
want to thank the organizers for the
invitation not just for this talk but to
be here the whole semester so before I
start there's a workshop the second
workshop is on solving polynomial
equations so this is jointly organized
with Frank's for Talay and then Pascal
Quran so we'll bring in lots of good
speakers to tell you more about solving
polynomial equations and their
applications as well the complexity of
them so for my first talk many of you
might be familiar with symbolic methods
so I want to sort of give you a quick my
interpretation of symbolic method and
then also sort of tell you the basic
idea of numerical methods and then the
rest of my talk will say try and answer
the question what this solve mean and
then my next lecture on Thursday I'll
actually go into more details about the
America's great geometry and how do you
actually solve things okay so from a
symbolic standpoint you can think of say
grosvenor basis or resultant eliminates
etc and what you want to do is you want
to take your system of equations so you
have a given a given system of equations
system of polynomial equations
let's say F 1 of X 1 through X and they
go to 0 through F X and what do these
methods do all of the symbolic
manipulations is they manipulate the
polynomials or I will say deform to
produce new sets of equations new
equations which are easier to solve so
we've been doing this in linear algebra
for a long time so let's write down a
linear system of equations so we have X
minus 9 y plus 8 Z is equal to 5/2 X
minus 3 y minus Z is equal to minus 5x
plus 3y minus 2 Z is equal to 2 in one
second can anyone tell me what the
solutions no okay good
suppose I did some manipulation and if
my math is correct these two sets of
equations define the same solution and
hopefully from the second one you're
able to actually see how to find the
solution Z is equal to five halves plug
that into here compute Y plug y&z into
here and compute X so these two sets of
equations define the same solution but
one of them is much easier to solve than
the other one so this is the basic idea
of say grosvenor basis is here you have
these so-called pivots in linear algebra
and pivots are they're placed with
leading terms or or the leading
monomials of algebraic equations so you
turn a system of equations which say is
dense into something which has sort of
nice pivots and that way you can easily
answer your question so this is how I
see symbolic methods it's turning your
system of equations into an easier
system that you can now quickly solve
alright let's move on to sort of numeric
so the basic thing of numerical
algebraic geometry the basic tool is
home Autopia continuation and the idea
is you want to solve f of X equal to 0
by first solving a new system G of X
equal to 0 there's a lot of art involved
with choosing this new system and we'll
talk about some of the foundational
ideas behind that throughout the the two
lectures the system you give me is too
hard to solve so I'm going to ignore
your system and solve my own system
that's easy to solve so for instance
suppose my f of X is x squared plus 3x
minus 5 and 2x y plus y squared minus 3x
plus 2 for instance you might see an
idea of how to solve this the first
one's quadratic and one variable you can
find the solutions plug it in and get to
get to eyes compare that with this
system G of XY is x squared minus 1 y
squared minus 1 you should be able to
immediately solve G and now what we want
to do is use the solutions from G to
give us the solutions to that's the
whole idea of this so we're going to set
up a home @lp
and for simplicity let's just take a
linear interpolation f of X times 1
minus T plus T times G and we want this
be equal to 0 so this defines a system
of equations and for simplicity let's
assume here that f is f1 through FN and
X is x1 through xn where these are the
same size so I have the same number of
equations as I have variables so I have
a well defined well constrained system
and now let's assume that G of X equal
to 0 as D solutions with determinant of
the Jacobian of G not 0 at each X star
such that G of X star 0 so no not 0 I
said not 0 it didn't write it very good
thank you so these are called the non
singular solutions so assume that all
the solutions are not singular this is a
system of equations of n plus 1 in n
plus 1 variables F there's an X's and
one T and n equations and n plus 1
variables so you would hope this defines
a curve and almost everywhere it does
and let me tell you what I mean by that
so what you should think about is your
tea here is a complex number and what
happens at T equal to want it so let's
put t equal to 1 and here 1 minus 1 is 0
so my F turn vanishes and I have 1 times
G is equal to 0 so essentially I have G
equal to 0 and G equal to 0 I have D
solutions everything is non-singular so
think back to analysis we have the
implicit function theorem tells us that
locally nearby my solutions can actually
continue as I change T so the implicit
function theorem
it says that for tea near one solution
passed X of T of H exists endorsement a
solution of G what is here so at every
point of G equal to zero I know that
there's a solution path passing through
there so as I vary T I get these nice
curves and what you can show is for
except for finitely many values of T
this is always true so move from
analysis local analysis to algebraic
geometry and except for finitely many
key starts we have exactly D solutions
all non-singular to H X so now the art
is we want to get to zero
we started at t equal to 1 we want to
get to zero we don't know if the path
along 0 to 1 is actually good and many
times it's not because the real numbers
have some interesting properties so many
times I'm gonna have some of these t
stars lying here but I know that there's
only finitely many things and over the
comp over the real numbers this is a
two-dimensional set the complex numbers
are two dimensions and so that means I
can draw an arc that misses these points
and that's gonna be my defamation I'm
going to deform along an arc that misses
these points how do you construct such
an arc well that's a probability one
statement and so let me tell you sort of
the whole idea how do you know you're in
a bad or very good your division how do
you know you're on a bad mark you have
less than these solutions or one of them
is singular you know you only know it
yes yes and this is exactly where the
probabilistic methods America
and so what I mean by that is methods
work except on is a risky closed proper
yes that's correct a priori I don't know
how to prove I have the correct solution
but if I have the wrong solution then I
can verify that I haven't seen you there
because I choose my G and because I've
chosen G I know I have that many
solutions think back to x squared minus
1 y squared minus one that has portion
you just have to exhibit them just write
them down this talk is over complex
numbers I'll leave Cynthia to maybe talk
about some kind of aspects of real
abstract geometry but I will mention
about real numbers very briefly in my
second talk if Cynthia doesn't say ok
good so what you move from in the
symbolic case in the symbolic case you
can prove that every computation you do
was correct you can prove that if you
subtract two integers you get another
integer and all of your computations in
your grosvenor phases are correct
whereas numerical methods we rely upon
the probabilistic nature of risky close
sets they're small the probability that
you a random point lies on a given to
risky set based on your caller bility
distribution is probability 0 so the
methods work with
by switching from always correct
provable results to probability one
results the idea is now that we can
solve much bigger polynomial systems and
once you know the answer afterwards you
can then go back and prove using your
favorite tools then what the method gave
you was correct
and there are several people in the
audience who have used numerical methods
to find the answer and then going back
with some other technique and actually
that answer was yes yes the okay so I'll
get into this very briefly but because
you're given F you can look at its
structure what are the degrees of it
what are the monomials that appear in it
what kinds of things should happen at
infinity that will lead you to design
gene to be to match this and there's an
art to to this I won't be able to say
much of it but I'll lead you there
another thing okay so that's my
introduction to the difference between a
symbolic and numerix because you have a
solution like this you know that X of T
is analytic with ancients X of T
equivalently equal to 0
and so what we've done is you can turn
this into a path tracking this defines a
curve parameterize by t and so you've
turned algebraic geometry into a
differential equation solver and so let
me tell you that this is what's called
the dabba Danko differential equation
we start at a known solution of G equal
to 0 and then we adjust with respect to
T based on Jacobi so you immediately see
from this differential equation my
Jacobian has to be full rank and order
for it to be invertible so here's where
I'm going to see if I run into problems
so we've turned solving polynomial
systems f of X equal to 0 into solving
differential equations and then use your
favorite differential equation solver to
come back to to find the solutions okay
good
questions so far so that's my brief
introduction to comparing symbolic to
the American now let's move on to what
we mean by salt I think maybe if you
could just give a little history as to
when these Holman pumping up it's very
hot so the history is quite interesting
in that home Autopia methods have been
used they predate computers home Autopia
methods have been used since sort of the
late 19th century for solving PDEs
and so PDE and obe people have been
using sort of home Autopia methanol to
solve their method at least from the
theoretically ruthless thing to hanko
differential equations so before people
were thinking of these paths using
topology and davidenko in the 1950s had
this idea instead of using topology
let's use differential equations and
come back to and this was about the mid
50's and then throughout the 60s and 70s
and then sort of exploding and
90s and 2000's a sort of wind home
talking about that sort of really took
off into algebraic geometry
I think the first people to do it work
came from Beckett in the design robotic
yes yes exactly so mechanical engineers
have been using these to design
mechanism since the late 50s early 60s
and the very basic first computers so
the the long computational history has
been there as well as the theory from so
as I move down the whole motoki it works
for square systems where the number of
equations is equal to another barriers
you can always it depends upon what you
mean by salt and that's what the next
whatever like the time I have left is
what do you mean by computing the
solutions do you mean computing some
components to mean finding isolated
points of an over determined system but
every problem can be reduced down into
exactly what I told you you have a
square system of polynomial equations it
takes some tricks to get it there but it
mainly depends upon the person asking
the right question what kind of
solutions to this system are you looking
okay so let's move on to solve what so
when you ask your favorite program to
solve this system what are you asking it
to do that's sort of the fundamental
problem here is trying to find out what
you're looking for so that the software
can give you the answer you're looking
for so let's think back to classical
times
so yeah absolutely
up till this point have you any reviews
this what I've used is that there's
finitely many solutions at the end
finitely many isolated points everything
here
this old deprivation works with any kind
of analytic function and so you can do
home a token continuation over an
ellipse you just can't prove that you
have all of the solutions you to get
sort of the methods to prove that you
find everything you want you have to use
outbreak yes it's so extent yes in this
yeah thanks
okay so let's think back to the ancient
period say Egyptians solve meant to sort
of write formulas in terms of the
coefficients so I hope everyone can
answer the first two right so X here is
minus B over a I'm assuming this is
linear which means a is nonzero it's
wrong to talk the next one I hope
everyone has gone through high school
good anyone knows the cubic formula it's
very complicated yes what about the
quartic formula has anyone ever looked
at the core Department okay good and
then what happens so I will and roughly
eighteen thirties no formula is written
no there's no algebraic formula there's
an analytic yes or no form with radicals
no formula involving plus minus times
divide radical such that to solve
general McClintock
very good
okay so I look at this and say 300 years
ago they predicted that computers were
going to take over all the great
challenges this shows that we need
computers to help us we need new
marriage to approximate our solutions we
need computers to refine to reinterpret
our polynomials so sort of 300 year old
math periods together with modern
computers sort of have led to this
computational algebraic geometric
repetitive sort of requirement that's my
my pitch that okay so we can't write
general formulas down but what we can
try to do is maybe solve needs to
compute a solution so I give you a
system f of X equal to zero and I ask
does there exist a solution or is there
no solution okay so let's say the
univariate case in a very case I give
you a univariate polynomial degree D
does there exist a solution yes
fundamental theorem about
good so Apollo univariate polynomial
degree D has D Bruce counting more
places so univariate polynomials and
this was used in the previous talk we
always build solutions exist
what about positive dimensional things
and this is Hilbert's we trust on sets
and it says that if F which is again an
f1 through FN equal to 0 it has no
solutions have no solutions if and only
if there exists g1 through GN such that
I can write one ok so how is this useful
in particular how is this useful to what
we're studying this semester let's look
at 3 by 3 matrix model
so pick your favorite our and look at
the system I won two are a Jake any
times B I ll see I and O minus K times L
AM XE race chroniker deltas of these MN
and OJ and here I move over all j k l m
o from one to three understand the
notation okay so you pick JK l and m o
in one two three and I'm gonna write
down this polynomial
okay so I have 729 pollinators I have
six choices here and three to the sixth
so what is yeah you got it
so the a ijk are are like our variables
yes
ABC our variables which live in CR
across three prospered various
indeterminacy
okay and O is an index index on it maybe
I should change it to P yeah and it'd
probably be better if I were Greek or
something because it's a completely
different type of index okay all right
okay just aesthetics yes so these have a
name these are called the Bret
polynomials and what's known about them
when R is less than or equal to 18 alpha
bar equal to 0 has no solutions
right these called friend because there
is a paper of Brent which were the first
ones to write them down if you read lot
of his paper he refers to this paper of
breath good so that means whenever R is
less than or equal to 18 I can find a
linear combination of early polynomial
combination in my ideal so that one is
in okay what's also now if R is greater
than equal to 23 have a bar equal to 0
so this was I guess blogger f of r equal
to 0 has solutions and the first one to
show this with lotterman 423 and so
between 9 19 and 22 unknown so you can
answer questions about complexity of 3x3
matrix multiplication just by trying to
exhibit or prove that no solutions exist
so you don't we don't care about all
solutions we just want to know does
there exist any solutions so what's the
relationship of this matrix
multiplication I if you if you have a
solution that leaves tell you exactly
how to do the matrix
I think this expresses I was confused
but this expresses that the tensor of
3x3 matrix multiplication yeah has
ranked the most yeah it's exactly this
corresponds to the tensor of matrix
multiplication and this corresponds to a
general tensor of rank R okay and it's
showing that the rank of this tensor is
the choice of pieces these would be
unusual yeah okay shirts are okay okay
okay how much talk to you okay so if
someone can answer this question between
19 and 22 the semester that'd be a great
advance
go ahead what's the problem a lot of
Barry there's 729 polynomials here
there's 27 times our barriers and so for
the are that we're interested in
this is under this is over determine you
have more polynomials than variables
numerical methods like well constrained
systems but here is a over determined
system what that means is any
perturbation here you're gonna get no
solution the american methods like
stability and so that's the fundamental
reason okay good so let's move on to
numerical methods how can you use
numerical methods to prove that there
exists a solution so proof there exist
the solution using the nurse so what I'm
looking for here is I'm looking forward
probably into their different questions
okay it will on if you take the closure
of those
and so now you have to sort of look and
see okay I have a subsystem which has a
solution but there could be many points
above it how do I find the one that
corresponds to the actual solution
follows yes okay so here we're really
looking for an integer or a rational
solution so one that we can just plug in
how could we use numerix if we don't
have such things that we can evaluate
and so here I'm thinking of my system
app and I've got a switch I will switch
the patient I'll stick with the same
notation and here axis X okay so I have
a well constraint system and now I take
the take my favorite point and I look at
what happens when I do a new iteration
so what is a new generation X zero minus
the Jacobian out of that inverse x and
now you can take this point x1 and do it
new generation on that and keep going
and so you get a sequence of points X 0
X 1 all the way down where XK is equal
to the new
about the print
okay
so if you know if the limit as K goes to
infinity XK exists then this limit is a
solution so if this has a limit then you
know you have a solution
another nice fact is that if the
Jacobian at my solution is invertible
then there is an open set open
neighborhood of X such that for all X 0
so open neighborhood you for all X 0 and
you the limit as K goes to infinity
maybe I should call Y so this thickness
if the inverse exists every frankly yes
if my solution is non singular so if my
solution here is non singular okay then
there's an open neighborhood such that
if I pick any point here the Newton's
method has to take me back and not only
that it has to take me back there fast
why J - my point X has to be in the
quadratic convergence
to the K minus 1 y 0 minus X beautiful
so not only do I have to converge to my
solution I have to converge there very
fast quadratic ok
so how do you prove you have such a
point how do you prove you have
convergence so prove quadratic
convergence you guys snails out for
example the nice thing about this is no
knowledge of X the limit point is needed
or any other solutions so I can use
alpha theory to test just by knowing
this point y 0 I don't even know how
many solutions do there exist other
solutions I can test everything locally
at my given point Lucario and I have
been discussing and there's many people
in the audience who would like maybe to
have some kind of seminar involving
Alpha Theory numerical solving this
thing so if you're interested we can
talk very good sorry but what about the
neighborhood
so when you apply the theory you know at
this point there exists some ball where
there's a solution that lives inside of
that ball is the knowledge of how big
the ball has to be needed and
if you know this point then yes you can
find bounds on the ball but if you don't
know that point and we're assuming we
don't then we just have some other point
does it converge so yes it's both ways
if you know X you can get an idea or
lower bounds on the size of U and if you
know y 0 you can get lower upper bounds
on the distance of the other if you know
X what do you care you're done right
exactly right but if you know X you're
done yeah but this is more about you
guess a walk get a visit in real life
you're guessing walk I stopped reading
it and then you exactly so take it back
to the homotopic continuation we follow
our path until we're close to the end
take that as our y zero and prove that
it converges that's sort of one way of
so I don't want to go into details today
but it essentially it's a rules for wind
Newton's method quadratic convergence
and if there's significant interest I
can include that in my talk on Thursday
if that would be of interest to would
you be interested in because I just have
no idea with them such a rule of the
place okay well let me tell you the
first thing is you need to know how far
does Newton iteration but you do and
then the second thing you need to know
how bad are your derivatives so this is
kind of like a condition number and this
is the distance and now you take alpha
to be the product of those two and if
this number it's small enough the point
one five I forget the magic number then
Newton's method converges method
converges quadratically I switched from
X to Y zero I apologize
sorry go that's the tune this is the two
more man this is the operator this is a
tensor and this is the operator normal
depth yes there is a beautiful upper
bound because this gamma is complicated
yes evolves high derivatives of order
that you can upper bound it by a
quantity condition number essentially
which only yes it's nice yes
there's a nice upper bound and that's
actually what what we implemented it of
the certified line if you have
polynomials this is a finite maximum and
so you can actually in theory and
compute it but to computing higher
derivatives and norms about this how
much time do I have
so symbolically or exactly if we can
produce the coordinates then we can just
evaluate it and see that's equal to zero
numerically we just have to get close
and never rely on some other theory to
prove that there is a solution okay
there was a quick aside here I made the
assumption that my solution was non
singular if you look at the system and
this is in your homework twenty nine
over sixteen and execute on this to X
plus y minus x squared the solutions of
this is the only the origin its
multiplicity 3 but if you take a random
point in c2 which is not the origin and
so that's part of your homework problem
is be careful when Jacobian is not
perfect you can get some crazy behavior
this is just a nice simple example of
some behavior ok so I leave that one to
the homework what's another way we can
think of solving equations
so maybe you want to think of solving
needs counting
so before I first said does there exist
a solution and now the next question is
how many solutions are there so to solve
my system means they count the number of
solutions to ok so in the univariate
case we already have the fundamental
theorem of algebra which says that a
degree D polynomial has ID roots what
happens in general well in general is
quite interesting the only things that
we know of sort of in general our upper
bounds so when we design hoe motoki's we
designed the G so that it has an upper
bound on the number of solutions and one
simple way to find upper bounds is basis
there so you mean if the number of
solutions of gene is an upper bound in
other solutions of that exactly yes very
good
so if f1 through FN let's go back to our
presentation then the set of solutions
and such that fi
0x4 1 to 10 if this and this then the
number of points is bounded by d 1 times
D denim and what I have to do is be
careful so what can go wrong well it
could go that I have infinitely many
points in here and how can I bound it
infinitely many points by this if then
let's go to this where V 0 equals the
isolated points in my solution set so if
I do ignore all the positive dimensional
components and just look at the isolated
points I'm gonna have finitely many of
them and a bound on the number of
isolated points moreover
my set of solutions are all isolated and
found as sharp on as risky open dense
subset of polynomials of degree D I what
I mean by that is if I take all of these
polynomials in particular Fi to be
general in the set of all polynomials of
that fixed degree D I then my bound is
sharp and all the points are isolated
they're all not singular
everything is nice so almost everywhere
they do stare in this chart what's the
problem the problem is many of the
polynomial systems we want to solve live
on this sort of singular focus they're
not on this Aristeas and that's where
the challenge comes in how can we handle
sort of this so-called bad set where
they seems they're in fact
okay so let's let me give you a
historical fact our historical example
of using basis theorem
and so mrs. Steiners problem I believe
1848 count the number conics tangent to
five given general lines honey's conics
given general conics sorry products and
I should look at my notes rather than go
on to good okay so pick five general
conics and now you want to count the
number of conics I can determine what
happens if I pick pick one cotton and
it's Jenna then there's going to be a
hypersurface of conics which are tangent
to that given one so there's a
hypersurface there's a hypersurface
of comics
tangent to the given one and the degree
of it is six good so now babies whose
parents all this question is asking is
how many points are in the intersection
on these five hyperflex so I'm
intersecting hyper planes hyper planes
are defined by a polynomial and so I
just intersecting five holders so Snyder
said the answer is and this is why
Steiner said well I have six polynomials
v Holland O'Neill's that degree six and
so I should expect 7776 solutions the
problem is this is not correct and the
reason for this is he forgot about the
double lines so this found this number
added the double lines inner and double
lines are some family but we're only
interested in the isolated points and
they've dealt with the family of double
lines lives in there as a
one-dimensional object and so you have
to remove
the count for the double lines and the
actual answer is 32 so just as Newton's
theorem Newton's method you have to be
careful when the Jacobian is not
invertible you have to be careful about
Bayes theorem when you have positive
dimensional things that log in they can
throw your counter good if you want a
nice historical or nice computational
who look at Frank's book which I believe
is upstairs in the library for this you
can ask so this was all over the complex
numbers now you can ask the real
question how many can be real so of
these 32 64
how many can be real and it turns out
that all of them can be real
there's a nice construction again in
Frank's book that shows that hey that
showed this dutiful that's pictures are
who also asked the question fulton asked
the question that enhance that question
any answer
that's good maybe me ask questions I
wonder what happens geometrically so you
you have this hype if you pick one
kaneki general position PCC finds a
hypersurface
of corn extension yes and then you take
the five of those and you intersect yes
so you will get I mean 3264 isolated
points plus post components of positive
dimension yeah and the solution positive
dimension are exactly the doubles what
is that it's a square yeah the cancer
for free yeah exactly that's a P it's
not P 2 and P 5 embedded okay all right
so the last thing I think I might be
running out of time
the last thing for your homework is to
look at polynomials like this and y
squared plus 5x plus 2y minus 3 and by
looking at polynomials like this I sort
of hope that you'll be thinking about
designing moment Opie's just solve such
as so let's look at this appearance I
have two quadratics degrees too
so bayes's theorem says is a genetic
mutation
absolutely but I have less than or equal
to four isolated solutions
how many do I actually have they
well this polynomial system has
structure and one of the structures it
has is that the X's only appear linearly
so if I look at what happens I can
rewrite my system in the following way I
have I had 2y plus 3 and then 4y minus
1/5 + y squared so because my X's only
appear linearly I can rewrite this as
sort of a matrix equation like this this
is a nonzero vector and whenever I have
a non-trivial kernel that means that
this matrix has a rank Division so this
implies that the determinant so let's
call this matrix a it doesn't depend on
X the determinant of a of why hasn't
equal to 0 and this is nothing more than
the resultant
so this is nothing more than the
resultant of that what's the degree of
this polynomial this is degree 3 and
it's univariate every polynomial of
univariate of degree three has three
solutions counting multiplicity that
turns out you can show that it's all the
multiplicity 1 and suppose I have a lie
that satisfies this I'm going to get a
unique X where this is true so this
turns out that this has three solutions
the nice thing about cubic equation
cubic things is you can simply write
down the discriminant and you can count
the number of real solutions so part of
your Homer gasps what's the number of
real solutions to this and you can do
that quickly with your spirit all right
so what is the additional structure of
my system here which reduced my count
from four different and it was the fact
that X is only appeared linearly whereas
my original polynomial where clock round
2 and so you can generalize this to a
multi and homogeneous bayes's theorem
and design coma taupe is based on it so
multi homogenius
hey and we're time constraints I'm just
kind of assume to mama Gina's casing and
here so assume that let's say that if my
system F is defined I need two variables
is defined on pick your favorite space
f-fine space products
or the reverse of them it the count is
the same clerk in one of them so how
many X's aren't there there's n XS how
many Weiser and why is it them then the
number of isolated points is less than
or equal to I'll write down the bound
and then I'll tell you all the
ingredients the coefficient of the term
alpha and x times theta and Y in the
polynomial R in the expression the
product I will 1 to n X plus D X 5
where F I has by degree X 5 okay
so that's a long complicated expression
let's look at it in this simple case and
then I'll be done for today
so this one is defined on C cross C
otherwise known as C 2 but I'm going to
think of this as C cross C because
that's how I'm gonna compactify it
that's P ones gossipy one okay so now
look at the degrees so what is my degree
of X in the first equation X appears
linearly so the degree in terms of X is
1 and the first equation y also here
something here so that's also 1 so this
is a quadratic polynomial that has by
degree one point let's look at the next
one X is only appeared linearly but why
appears quadratically so it's a
quadratic polynomial of type 1 2 and all
this is saying is now take the
permanence of this matrix
one to take the permanence because you
have to traverse one X in one line and
the number of ways to make this matrix
go through is exactly the permanent and
so this is 2 X 1 plus 1 times 1 which is
3 if you want to use this fancy
coefficient expression here what we're
really looking at is what is the
coefficient of the cross term alpha
times beta and alpha plus beta times
alpha plus 2 beta coefficient of alpha
is 1 coefficient of beta is 1
coefficient of alpha is 1 coefficient of
beta is 2 in the second expression we
show the whole thing data they're just
simple symbols oh I see symbols
yeah so all I'm asking is what is the
cross term here so I need alpha times
beta that gives me 2 and beta times
alpha that give me hope this one it's in
my cross country
so with that I in the homework I asked
you to find the two homogeneous baizhu
count for eigenvalue computing
eigenvalues of a matrix which is a nice
sort of expansion of this all right I
think just stop there
go back here probably wasn't finding a
nice are people interested in questions
like finding a small yeah so in the home
Autopia construction going back to it
going back to the beginning because it's
sort of with probability one what people
do in practice is pick different G's and
do the computation and make sure to sort
of gift repeatable results that so you
know that for any particular G if I set
it up with probability one in a work but
now you have to understand that that
works over talking about the Bluths male
model that works over that model of
computation however my computer has
finitely many bits in it and to do the
numerical computation so you use
adaptive precision increase sort of the
accuracy that you have but then also
just make different smart systems and
rerun the same problem and make sure you
get repeatable results
yeah there's gonna what it turns out is
there gonna be a whole family of G's
that work can you actually pick one you
make me ask you oh you give a list and
one of them to work yes yes yeah so
you're gonna have what you're gonna have
is a whole family of them which all work
and so anyone in this family will I hope
I answered
okay this kind of can lead to proof of a
lower bound for instance if I give you
some tensile strength and you are free
when they prove if the polynomial system
is small enough that you can actually
solve it nonzero then there's exactly
zero so you have a say in that
several villages when your knowledge and
ability to identify it would be nice
sort of changing the subject is there a
good nice story for the worst piece
about it for this problem the worst case
is you're gonna have singularities and
you're gonna hit the singularities are
you how all this importance so let me
rephrase what I'm talking about so there
are numerical methods to handle the
singularities but to get provable
results about singularities or not for
example I don't know if Peter will talk
about this throughout his talks or
someone you can use alpha theory to
certifiably pleat track these paths and
you can prove every step along the way
that everything is non-singular and it's
nice and if if the whole path is not
singular then you get a finite time
algorithm to track that path and compute
the inputs whereas in practice so that's
in theory and practice you you do
different tricks to handle singularities
one interesting question is suppose I
give you a numerical approximation of a
singular point how do I know that there
actually is a singular point for that
system Newton's method probably will
either converge linearly or diverge or
who knows what happens so are there
different approaches to be able to you
can take the numerix go back into
symbolic expressions and then sort of
use that symbolic expression to prove
there's a senior there's a singularity
there but it's really a if trying to
find good algorithms before singular
cases are really hard
there are heuristics that work pretty
well but if you want prove ability but
to simply yeah governor basis absolutely
right and these is there any concise the
worst case doubly exponential it's
basically in vary the number of terms
the degree and the number and then okay
so it's doublet
a number of variables polynomial in
degree I think I think I made my point
but you know it's probably I think it's
well known I should add the complexity
the only single explanation with you
only if you just want to find the
solution in geometric way but however if
you want to understand it algebraically
with multiplicities and everything
that's okay so we drop about this race
so my diversity story or similar
solution was correct moment if you want
the worst case for Kamata P we need to
make concessions for instance you should
admit that the input is by integers and
the same my integers the coefficients of
the polynomial functions or whatever so
in that case it is possible to get in
terms of other things of the sign of
those integers assuming the the system
is non degenerate so the ring will be a
worst case for non degenerate existence
and you don't know if your system is the
generator not that the beginning worst
case of general second
but you can get usually you should point
out when you come back after precision
you can notice that you're getting
closer see you Larry absolutely with the
condition number it's really important
for the algorithm absolutely and I hope
Peter might say something about this on
I think I would have talked about it in
the workshop
okay another talk about different things
okay
very basic things very good so do and
because I wrote up gamut here there's
this conditioning that gamma handles and
that sort of tells you is worth how many
digits do I need to accurately handle my
voice their conditioning is very
important and I think you're talking but
other questions yes number of possible
solutions is there likely the notion of
an average case number of solutions for
appear within a time
position Basu's theorem it is sharp in
in the average case over the complex
numbers is risky if you if I think
general public if you are over the
complex numbers is not a very
interesting question you know this is
almost surely we you will get this
number
however over the wheel it's very
integers and there are lots of
interesting open problems there that's
all for it there is this very nice
result by shoeprints mail which is kind
of an average Basel serum.you says that
if you equations are chosen at random
according to some thousand inventing
Gaussian distribution then the expected
number of real solutions is just the
square root this is very and there's a
certain type of probability distribution
for that and if you change your
probability distribution to give it a
different expected number
I didn't care I think over keyword
Google keywords
- flexibility if I may advertise my
father that I roll in difficult the
tightest condition lays on the Shelf we
have there the alphasphere in the gamma
theory and we also have to be square all
the product of the degree so very good
now there's a book on the third award
and it's that's it's not the main focal
spec but thanks
so if there's no other question so let's
again